hey out there you guys it's Friday again
and it's time for a movie review doing
another kind of obscure one this time
around yeah this is kind of one that you
I don't think I actually saw this at the
time that it came out yeah small speak
evil speech yeah it reason why any one
reason why it's stuck out in my mind is
cuz this came out when I was in military
school yeah SC MA and this is happening
this movie is happening in a militaries
yeah it's said in a military which is a
trip because during this era there was a
long there was a bunch of little
military school type based movies coming
out and I don't know what started it I
don't know if it was omen to that
started it but might be you know this
movie does seem a little bit like it was
a little bit before this yeah might have
been and in the Los Angeles basin there
was my school and another one could
which is Southern California Military
Academy
SC ma and the other one was called the
Army Navy Academy and I don't know if
they ever used Army Navy can be in a
school but they used mine SEMA they they
used our school in a movie
yeah and so long what we call
over-the-top yeah I was like not this
one no no this one I think is so they're
supposed to be kind of I think they're
talking about Army Navy Academy because
that was Army Navy Academy was like a
10th grade up through high school maybe
you know and 10th through 12th I think
is what I read
yeah I think it was 10th or 12 maybe
even maybe even just had some college
courses there I know that when you got
out of Army Navy Academy you could
actually go into the service as an NCO
yeah you know so they were making NCOs
there so somehow this these were good
scenes and backdrops for movies I think
the Hollywood guys thought that was
interesting I think they also think they
thought it was kind of freakish it was
there it was the Reagan era and a lot of
guys that were in Hollywood really
didn't vote for Reagan and then there
was kind of a negative spin on a lot of
military schools they were kind of miss
portrayed you know is what they were
like
but it showed up a lot of movies yeah
this one is actually um it's it's not a
real military academy it's in the movie
it's called West and over it actually
wasn't even filmed at a real military
academy it's actually filmed at like a
Spanish mission yes the thing is is
military academies in California where
we're in that style mine was a nest oh
yeah that's why they did that they
wouldn't be able to actually film a
military academy they wouldn't be able
to go in there and film because some
students actually lived in them and they
were working you know there was constant
activity in them the the funny thing
about this movie like I said I don't
remember ever seeing it or really
hearing about it that much but you
remembered it yeah and although I don't
remember if you remembered like the
title of it but we eventually like track
yes remember the time because it's it's
kind of a strange premise in a lot of
ways it's kind of like the you know
loser gets revenge on his bullies type
genre yeah and kind of like Carrie
yeah um like like the omen to a little
bit there was actually another movie
that came out either right before this
one or right around the same time that
was called fear no evil that had about
the same that had the same premise and
976 evil if you saw that one about the
phone line
what was it was the dorky guy so same
kind of thing one of the really
interesting things about this at the
time you know when this came out the
hottest home computer you can get was
like the Apple 2e
yeah all right and this movie featured
an Apple 2 computer in it and a bunch of
for the time really awesome computer
graphics and it was mixed with Satanism
and would really capture your
imagination when you were a kid you're
like wow you could use the computer to
conjure the devil yeah that's I mean
it's looking very strange like I said
you got a whole loser getting revenge
type thing
then you have the whole Satanism angles
yeah and then you have like computer
technology yeah computers are magic -
yeah and I kind of laughed when we watch
this is it actually is an apple 2e in
this wood that he uses to like summon
Satan or yeah and it's not really Satan
he's actually channeling a Satanist from
the past it was in the area yeah he's
like named Esteban yeah and he's played
by
Richard Moll who played bull on Night
Court yeah so if you ever want to see
this was actually before that court but
if you ever want to see Paul from Night
Court your movie and I swear to God that
man Kirk in this movie is the same kid
who played Chaka it's not it's not it
looks just like this is actually this is
Clint Howard is the main character in
this yeah and he actually got quite
famous later on just being you know
being a cult kind of figure it's Ron
Howard's brother obviously and Ron
Howard has put him in a few of his
movies as well but Clint Howard he's
always he's kind of a cult hero I guess
because he was in so many of these like
cheesy ass 80s horror movies this was
actually his first major role his first
starring role he had been a TV and stuff
like that before that but the poor guy
is like so funny-looking that it just
seems like he can never really catch a
break you know what I mean he can never
like be a leading man or anything like
that like a unibrow book yeah cuz he's
so weird looking like I think they made
him look worse in this movie I mean he
is for real funny looking Charlie sweat
it's like I'm not sure like I think he
might have a toupee in this and I'm not
sure if that's a real partial unibrow or
just looks like Chaka to me I thought he
was Chuck yeah watching it cuz he was
like it looks like chalkie's like I
wonder if he played Chaka when he was a
kid there was no Land of the Lost and
like I was sitting there going so the
age should be about right I was like you
know that maybe so I looked it up this
is I looked up chalk out Kapadia and
it's not it's a different guy but he
does really look like him though but
what's cool about the movie is that the
Satanism gets involved and the kid gets
satanic powers and he wreaks revenge on
a bunch of [ __ ] classmates and staff
from the military school yeah it's kind
of like Carrie but there's some really
cool scenes in and him hovering with
swords and don't fire ball type [ __ ]
yeah pretty awesome the interesting
thing about this movie is that I mean I
can see how if
people don't really have a lot of
patience it might seem like there's like
a really lot of buildup because really
the first two-thirds three-quarters of
this movie is him getting picked on yeah
and I mean it's it's really terrible
like you can you kind of really have to
sympathize with the dude because it's
like he's so pitiful and he's so
funny-looking
and it's like everybody hates him he's
like an orphan he's only at this school
because you know it's he's like a
welfare case yeah um you know see so
he's there and he's like poor and like
all the other kids like even the fat
kids pick on him yeah sake he only has
one friend who's like the dude was on
some fresh prince of bel-air silver
spoons are one of those shows
I remember watching it you know and guys
from our Academy we loved it but we
would also comment Wow what kind of
Military Academy is that because
actually kids that went to military
academies most of them asked to go I
asked to go and most of us were day
students and they didn't tolerate any
misbehavior it was all good kids yeah
there was really nothing unusual about
them you know what I mean they were just
like regular schools like kinda like a
Catholic school type when I wouldn't
call it a Catholic school no but we know
today more like a regular kind of
private school it was like mixed with
the Cub Scouts and the Boy Scouts that's
all it was yeah but people who didn't go
to him thought that there was like
sinister [ __ ] going on at him yeah but
there's a whole like interviews about
are not interviews a documentaries about
my school on YouTube yeah just look at
SCM egg no and it'll come up yeah it's
basically kind of a thing where it's
almost kind of like carries like all
these people that are picking on because
not just the other students it's like
teachers and [ __ ] too
it's like really the only guy that likes
him he has one friend that kind of
sticks up for him the cook you know is
nice to him and [ __ ] like that but other
than that just everybody picks on this
poor kid and it's like he's and it is
hard like I said not to sympathize with
him because he's just so you know dorky
and it's like and I feel like that's
probably a natural thing that Clint
Howard does I mean it's just like he's
so awkward and it's like he just trips
over
just like always falling and he has
these like really dorky Express very
cringy yeah all day he's cringe cringe
II character yes comes back with the
power save - in a way you can kind of
like understand why and everyone picking
on him is such [ __ ] that it's like
you're like yeah man get get in there
summon Satan and she's like get rid of
all this and then and then and then like
the the janitor threatened to rape yeah
never that did yeah there's a crazy
yeah crazy it's like like I said it
takes a while to get where it's going I
should note that for a while this movie
was actually on the UK's infamous video
nasties list you actually won't know why
that is until about the last he'll go oh
that's way but there's like a lot of fun
stuff in this but like I said really the
the crazy you know batshit insane stuff
doesn't really happen until the end
although you do get to see a naked lady
getting eaten by pigs yeah I normally
would it's kind of a good thing this
would have been a good candidate for
Tom's shitty movies on you know YouTube
but this one was actually good enough to
actually have a full review on yeah 13
o'clock and it is a low-budget movie but
it's pretty well made yeah you can tell
that the people that made this for
competent the score and this and the
sound effects you can tell directly
whoever did those had experience with
television these are a lot of the same
television special effects you'll get a
little sound cues yeah we're just ramped
it to the 70s almost like a 70s sitcom
but it uh it was low-budget but it was
kind of effective it delivered it
actually showed you what it promised to
show you and a lot of movies from this
period would promise a lot on the poster
and in a trailer but then when you saw
him there's really nothing to him
doesn't actually did deliver yeah like I
got like a more action-packed more of a
juvenile version of Oldman - yeah an
omen cuz like I said the last ten
minutes are like yeah pretty gnarly
there's just that kind slang everywhere
that's getting ripped
all kinds of yeah it goes getting it
goes it goes pretty ghetto ah it's
amazing yeah but here's the thing that I
this did actually did not occur to me
while I was watching the movie it kind
of occurred to me afterward
why does a military academy have a pig
sty
well I think it was warmed up with a
farm and they were growing their own
food isn't that what was that I think
that's what they were trying all right
there chart their chores were to also
work in the farm grow food but that's
military Kennedy's weren't like that
yeah that's they just wanted pigs
because of that thing in the Bible where
it's like she just puts demons and the
pigs in bubble and then he could like
control things that's kind of what I was
thinking the only accurate portrayal of
a milk of a California military school I
ever saw was on over the top and
Sylvester Stallone son play is an SCM a
student actually show the real students
the real cat is their real cadre you
know they're there now it's not at the
correct location they took it to a much
nicer location didn't look like a
Spanish fort just look like a I don't
know the Washington Monument or
something but that is actually what
they're like they're there nothing
sinister was going on in him well you
know this was actually it was directed
by Erik Weston and this was actually his
first directorial job and he didn't do
another horror movie until 2011 which
seems like kind of a shame but this
movie actually cost a million dollars to
make which wasn't chump change for a
horror movie of this type back then I'm
not gonna say it's not like some hugely
like forgotten like genius movie or
anything like that but if you really
like satanic movies like from the late
70s and early 80s which I do if you like
the whole Revenge of the Nerds onra and
you want to see something that's like
super super crazy um like I said it's
it's kind of a long slog like a lot of
it the first part of the movie is like
kind of building up his character and
watching him get picked it was so good
though yeah and stuff like that no I'm
just saying well you know if people are
pretty good it takes a while for but the
end part yeah is amazing it pays off
you can watch for free they have a good
HD copy of it up on YouTube it hasn't
been taken down yet yeah it's still
there what what the hell channel is that
on we're watching it I don't know we can
probably put a link somewhere in the
comments or just yeah I'll have to go
find it but um they must have come up
with come out with re-release to this on
blu-ray or something yes I actually
wouldn't mind having this one on on a
blu-ray would probably be pretty good to
have in a collection the thing that made
me laugh to about the Apple 2 was that
it almost had like a proto Google
Translate exactly translate no because
he was translating all the Latin all the
Latin that was in this book it was way
ahead of the time if you had an apple 2e
no you couldn't do much with home well
that's kind of funny like he was yeah
pretty much I could draw like we could
play wizardry yeah our Oregon Trail or
something yeah but yeah Jones ripoff it
was kind of like pitfall had an Aztec
motif to it oh yeah we got those in we
got computers that's how old I am we got
computers and I was eight you would tear
the keyboard up you'd break the [ __ ] out
of those keyboards of planets cool get
the spacebar over and over again and it
was like a big deal like we got these
[ __ ] things it's amazing it's like
where I can hold like 1k or something
yeah it was more than that muhfucka good
it could hold 30,000 Apple to ease now
yeah that's amazing in it the thing that
yes so I think that that's kind of
something that made this one gave this
one like a little bit of originality was
the fact that he sort of used the
computer like was the computer possessed
or was the computer like acting as like
a way for Esteban to come back yes Tomas
I think he came back through the
computer through the cyber world somehow
it it's just - movie magic because of
Clint Howard his character's name is
Cooper Smith by the way which I don't
think is Stanley Cooper Smith and like
all his stupid classmates just call him
Cooper dick all the time like that's the
best you could think of but but um the
graphics on it and in the computer
almost as good as Tron and
they were actually it wasn't bad it
wasn't bad good time it is I don't think
it was computer graphics I think it was
animation animation it probably it looks
a lot more like animation but yeah it's
just I think that gives this one
something of like a little bit of a
weirdness a little you know a little
something-something because you know
what I love kind of the juxtaposition of
like the ancient Satanist [ __ ] and you
know he's a Spanish monk who ended up in
California somehow I guess he got
banished banished from being Satanist a
member yes and I also have to say that
one of my very favorite parts of this
movie like happens almost immediately
after the credits where father Esteban
like cuts off the person's head and then
they and then they edit it like to a
soccer ball I [ __ ] love that [ __ ]
it's like a really funny edit this
actually has a lot of comedy to it I
wouldn't call it a horror comedy but it
actually does have like comedic moments
just because Clint Howard's character is
so dorky and awkward and it's like you
kind of feel bad for him but then you're
like man would him because he's always
he's kind of whiny - I gotta say it's
just a very watchable movie it is it's
like I said it's not one of those ones
where it's like oh this is fantastic and
I can't believe anyone forgot about it
but it's a really interesting premise
and it's like a really interesting gotta
be the right mood for it yeah maybe you
know you had a few drinks yeah like you
know the end of it is super fun and like
the end of it is super gory like I said
and it was on the video nasties list for
a while yeah just because of those last
move it's not obviously it's not cut
anymore but they but back then it was
even it's it's one of the lesser-known
ones that was on that infamous list I
still wanted to do like I remember I did
a show about the the video nasties yeah
I've always been fascinated by that
guy's stuff cuz I lived in the UK for a
little while but yeah this is like you
know this is just one that we kind of
wanted to do because we saw it a long
time ago I had never seen it yeah it's
good you just remembered it cuz it was
set in a military school and it was one
that yeah and it's good enough to talk
about on 13 o'clock I like I I find it
quite enjoyable actually yeah it's free
you can go watch it and yeah well so far
and it you can watch a good copy of it
yeah I'll put yeah I'll put a link in
the description so if you want to watch
it for free until somebody finds out
about and they take it down but like I
said I think there is a blu-ray out now
with you know it's probably scream
factory I think they're probably so you
know that's got kind of a lot of a lot
of cool extra isn't [ __ ] on it so if you
want to check it out you should and yeah
I think it was a making-of somebody was
talking about as a making Evan there's a
bunch of on the blu-ray ya interview so
funny even transfers had like a little
making of in the blu-ray edition of it
that I have in there talking about
trances like a Citizen Kane not only
that like oh yeah I like saying I love
this a piece-of-shit movie transfers
those it was this okay when when he came
out when you were a kid when I revisited
it I was like it's totally incoherent
well that's the thing they want so much
footage what's the like what's the
alternative though it's like if you have
to I mean you may be contractually
obligated nowadays probably to do some
extra [ __ ] right or the DVD or the
blu-ray release so what are you gonna do
you're just gonna sit there and go this
movie sucked they made a lot of
transfers movies you know I think it
went up like seven or eight for all I
know they got better as they went along
they must have seen phantasm did
phantasm uh actually gets better as it
goes I actually like the second one
better than the first one
well haven't seen the third one yet
though no I haven't seen everybody says
they get better as they go so I need to
get back yes that would be a very rare
thing well they all have humble origins
yeah and then people care about it and
they care about the mythos and they you
know the meaning they're written
correctly they can't get better yeah a
lot of times they get worse because you
have an original idea and then later on
the studio's want to bring it down to a
PG level and they start selling to kids
gets worse and worse it's like like
Conan movies and [ __ ] yeah they just
want to break oh oh we're just gonna try
and make another one let's keep dumbing
it down yeah they're just trying to make
it like feel the wider one yeah like
predator
but yeah yeah whatever but yeah so like
I said I'll put a link in the
description if you want to watch this
for free it's pretty entertaining and
the ending is actually pretty bad [ __ ]
and saying soon I should probably check
that out
and that will do it for this latest
movie review
remember if you would like to support
the show you can go to our patreon page
which is patreon.com slash 13 o'clock
podcast or you can go to our blog which
is 13 o'clock podcast wordpress.com and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account also check out our zazzle
store at zazzle.com slash 13 o'clock we
have like a lot of t-shirts and a tote
bag that you may purchase if you so
desire and remember our regular episodes
come out every Tuesday and our movie
reviews come out every Friday we will
see you next time bye